immer wieder gibt es meldungen die die
zerstörung der erde durch einen fremden
planeten vorhersagen teilweise werden
diese meldung mit planet iks also dem
neunten planeten in verbindung gebracht
der dieses jahr aus der bahn gerät und
auf der erde zu fliegt dabei hat der
planet an so ungünstigen an zumwinkel so
dass er nicht entdeckt werden kann was
ist an dieser these dran sind wir in
gefahr jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
wir haben hier ja schon öfter über den
neunten planeten berichtet und erst
kürzlich wie schwer er zu entdecken ist
und auch zuschauer vom krieg so haben
mich schon gefragt was ist mit der these
auf sich habe dass dieser neunte planet
oder ein anderer planet aus dem
sonnensystem mit der erde zusammenstoßen
wird ich habe mich daraufhin mit dieser
these beschäftigt und mir mal angesehen
welche veröffentlichungen es dazu gibt
und ich bin tatsächlich oft einiges
gestoßen immer wieder ist da zu lesen
dass der planet nibiru auf die erde
stürzen und sie zerstören wird das
verbreitet natürlich angst und schrecken
und wenn es so wäre oder auch nur die
wahrscheinlichkeit bestünde dann müsste
man ja dringend handeln laut berichten
würden dass die eliten der welt ja auch
tun und hätten sich schon entsprechende
bunker gebaut die sie im ernstfall
schützen würden und dass sogar die nasa
beschäftigt sich mit dem planeten die
büro und einer möglichen kollision weil
auch hier ständig danach gefragt wird
laut nasa gibt es rund zwei millionen
webseiten die sich mit einer möglichen
kollision beschäftigen und auch ein
datum wird schon genannt es ist der
fünfte oktober 2017 das wird im buch
planet x1000 seventeen arrival genannt
die these von dieser kollision wird zum
ersten mal von nancy lieder 1995
aufgestellt sie ist kontakte rinn und an
medien implantat in ihrem gehirn durch
dass sie in der lage ist signale von
außerirdischen aus dem stern system z
red die kuh die zu empfangen ermöglicht
ihr den empfang dieser botschaft david
stellt in seinem buch fest dass es immer
mehr erdbeben stürme und sonstige
naturkatastrophen gibt er bekommt dabei
unterstützung von unternehmer robert
vicino der war es nämlich mehr über die
vorbereitungen der eliten auf der welt
er sagt der daily mail zitat sie müssen
sich selbst fragen warum hat russland
gerade mit 40 millionen menschen den
ernstfall geprobt es gibt keinen zweifel
daran dass das ende kommt es wird episch
seien direkt aus der bibel so läuft kann
ich echt lieber ernst bleiben es gibt
keine ich zähle nochmal nach keine
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung zu
einem planeten der mit der erde
zusammenstößt und bitte gegen implantat
hakt es noch allein schon dass die
ankündigungen dieser katastrophe dieses
jahr jubiläum feiert nibiru sollte
bereits 2003 2012 im september 2015 dann
verschob auf den dezember 2005 sind dann
im september 2016 und jetzt also im
oktober 2017 mit der erde kollidieren
und der unternehmer robert vicino stellt
schutzbunker herum will sie verkaufen da
ist ihm jedes mittel recht und der ein
oder andere superreiche verrückte wird
eben vielleicht glauben und ich kann nur
sagen hey das ist sämtliches quatsch mit
soße jeder kann es selbst
wissenschaftlich überprüfen wir hatten
sie ein video mit niedrigen wissenschaft
ist eine tolle methode sie seit
tausenden jahren immer wieder bewährt
hat sie ist super einfach und leicht zu
verstehen und jeder also auch ihr könnt
es checken was braucht es also für eine
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis punkt eins
jemand stellt eine these auf er oder sie
hat gelernt mit wissenschaftlichen
methoden umzugehen und kennt sich in dem
fachgebiet aus beim planeten wäre das
zum beispiel eine astrophysikerin oder
ein astrophysiker sie oder er hat zum
beispiel etwas beobachtet am besten
werden weitere belege für die
beobachtung gesammelt wurde zum beispiel
ein planet beobachtet dann wird nach
weiteren beweisen gesucht zb nach
veränderten umlaufbahn die daten von
teleskopen werden durchsucht und so
weiter das wird dann veröffentlicht
punkt 2 dann versucht jemand diese these
zu widerlegen oder zu bestätigen er
wendet dafür weitere methoden zur
überprüfung an sammelt weitere daten und
noten und nur dann wenn das geschehen
ist und die these mit einer gegenprobe
in frage gestellt und dann bestätigt
wurde ist es eine wissenschaftliche
erkenntnis vorher ist es eine hypothese
selbst die oder der wissenschaftler der
sie aufgestellt hat würde nie etwas
anderes behaupten wie sieht es also beim
libro aus da haben wir schon das problem
mit punkt eins eine kontakten mit einem
implantat naja das erfüllt er die
bedingungen für eine einweisung in die
psychiatrie und das meine ich ernst als
dass sie eine gute experte für
exoplaneten abgeben würde aber es gibt
noch einen weiteren haken bei punkt eins
keine beweise auch david mitchell bild
in seinem buch herum und will etwas von
verstärkten erdbeben und stürmen und vom
biblischen beweisen bei der these der
erdbeben viel zum beispiel die
physikalischen grundlagen dafür dass ein
planet der ferne der mars jupiter oder
venus so weit sein muss ansonsten hätten
wir ja sehen müssen solche effekte
hervorrufen kann das entspricht zwar der
romantischen vorstellung oder
unromantischen vorstellungen eines
weltuntergangs hat aber mit der realität
einfach nichts zu tun und zu biblischen
beweisen da brauche ich ja wohl nichts
zu sagen alles was die bibel mit
beweisen zu tun hat ist dass
wissenschaftler darüber kenntnis haben
ob die darin beschriebenen ereignisse
oder personen so oder anders existiert
haben oder eben nicht keine prophezeiung
in dem buch ist eingetreten oder hat
sich auch nur angekündigt warum auch es
würde auch keinen sinn machen dass ein
angeblich gütiger gott die welt
vernichtet zwar wird die erde irgendwann
mal im räderwerk des universums zermalmt
aber nicht 2017 und nicht durch nibiru
sondern durch die sonne und es ist noch
ein paar milliarden jahre hin das ist
bekannt und wissenschaftlich bewiesen
und vorher werden wir vielleicht mal ab
und zu von einem asteroiden getroffen
diese gefahr ist bekannt und real und
wir wissen allerdings überhaupt nicht
wann und wo es gibt also reale gefahren
aber dafür gibt es auch thesen die auch
bestätigt wurden wissenschaftlich und
genau das ist bei der niveau geschichte
nicht der fall nicht nur die these ist
höchst fragwürdig weil sie auch durch
rein gar nichts wissenschaftlich belegt
ist es gibt auch keine wissenschaftliche
überprüfung und da macht es überhaupt
keinen sinn auch nur einen gedanken
daran zu verwenden da ist mir echt mein
gehirn zu schadet ja nach diesem check
kann ich nur sagen ein hirngespinst der
weltuntergang fällt mal wieder aus über
den nächsten weltuntergang halten euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden dafür mir
hier einfach ein abo aufs auge drücken
dann verpasste er kein video mehr bei
ticks und science fiction und vergesst
nicht mehr einen
genau auf die glocke zu geben hier geht
es zu den meistgeklickten videos von
pixum für den unwahrscheinlichen fall
dass er noch nichts abonnenten seit und
schreibt mir doch mal in die kommentare
welche verschwörungstheorien ich noch so
vorstellen soll und gerne auch überprüfe
das mache ich sehr gerne also bis dann
bleibt